I've said it before and I will say it
again for a document summarizing an
investigation that supposedly totally
clears the president no collusion no
obstruction witch-hunt presidential
harassment all that stuff
Trump's going crazy to prevent the
release of the document which supposedly
totally exonerates him and the big news
that we learned from yesterday is that
Donald Trump is asserting now executive
privilege over the entire unredacted
Moeller report understand the sort of
process that this has gone through
Trump's attorney General William Barr
released a redacted version of the
Moller report a couple of weeks ago and
even in its redacted form it was
absolutely devastating to Trump it's
cited quote substantial evidence of
obstruction of justice it found it could
not exonerate Donald Trump from
obstruction of justice it found that of
the fourteen different possible
instances of obstruction all three legal
requirements were met in eight of those
fourteen possible obstructive acts
that's really really bad but this was
only the redacted version of the report
and Democrats have been working to get
their hands on the unredacted version of
the report because there was so much
blacked out material in that redacted
version pages and pages some pages have
almost nothing other than like the
number of a footnote visible and the
source of the footnote everything else
completely blacked out so Democrats
understandably are thinking if the
redacted version is this devastating to
Donald Trump and the people around him
we've got to get our hands on an
unredacted version and William bar has
been resisting that he has been going
out of his way to a stone wall those
requests at every opportunity and now
that it's starting to look a little
dicey for William Barr
Trump has deserted executive privilege
over the entire reports in order to hide
those redacted portions before we go any
further what is executive privilege
executive privilege is the privilege
claimed by the president for the
executive branch of the United States
government and that's key because it
relates to co-equal branches of
government
it's the privilege of withholding
information in the public interest this
is all coming to a head because House
Democrats are looking at holding
Attorney General William bar in contempt
of Congress for his refusal to release
to them the unredacted version of the
report Trump jumping in now and
asserting executive privilege is an
attempt to preempt this and get around
the entire conversation about contempt
of Congress by William Bar and the crazy
thing about this is that the report has
endless evidence of obstruction which
his Attorney General Trump's Attorney
General William bar is refusing to
release which is another obstructive act
in other words bar is obstructing in
order to prevent more evidence of trumps
obstruction to be public which now
Donald Trump is compounding by asserting
executive privilege which is in and of
itself another obstructive act although
unlikely to be one that rises to the
level of criminality what a Sarah
Huckabee Sanders say about all of this
she's saying that the people breaking
the law are the members of the House who
are trying to do oversight take a look
at this quote where she said yesterday
the American people see through chairman
Adler's desperate ploy to distract from
the president's historically successful
agenda that's a lie and our booming
economy neither the White House nor
Attorney General bar will comply with
chairman Adler's unlawful and reckless
demands nothing unlawful about them
reckless is of course subjective faced
with chairman Nadler is a blatant abuse
of power there is no such abuse and that
the Attorney General's request the
president has no other option than to
make a protective assertion of executive
privilege almost nothing that she said
is true I think we could agree that she
used exclusively words from the English
language beyond that I don't think I
would agree about anything in that
statement but Sarah Huckabee Sanders the
president's agenda is not historically
successful the demands from the house
are not unlawful their proper legal
requests I don't even want to talk about
the Moller report itself here because
this is about a much bigger crisis the
administration has
Wow dude what is supposed to be balanced
power and checks and balances as
established by the founders of the
United States of America Republican
indifference is allowing this to
continue coequal branches of government
right that requires that when Trump
disregards the framework of how those
checks and balances work the House and
Senate need to balance it out and go
beyond partisanship but Republicans
simply refuse the Attorney General says
Trump can legally stop any investigation
into himself the Justice Department says
you can't or you don't or you shouldn't
indict a sitting president of the United
States what matters is they won't do it
this is not presidential harassment this
is a de facto presidential immunity that
goes completely outside what the
founders of the country actually wanted
and intended if we care about what the
founders wanted and intended which the
constitutional conservative right claims
to you have to call this out is
sickening you have to call Republicans
out for standing by and implicitly
rubber stamping it by their inaction and
it has to end in one one way shape or
form unfortunately the most direct path
to ending it it's probably going out and
voting Trump out in November of 2020
because there's no evidence anyone in
power on the Republican side is going to
actually take any decisive action here
and that's maybe the biggest tragedy of
it all that goes beyond the content of
the Moller report it goes beyond Trump's
14 potentially obstructive acts it's
more about what does this mean about the
basic foundations our country is built
on and I see it going nowhere quite
frankly if you disagree with me let me
know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka is a
great service that I use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information in inside
from each book and I've listened to a
ton of books on blink Asst I recently
checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book bs
jobs by David Graeber which I listen to
on bling cos they're constantly adding
new books to the platform you will never
run out of fascinating and critically
acclaimed books to enjoy and our
audience can get a seven day free trial
by going to blink Escom slash Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube I'm putting a
link in the video description and after
the free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa k ma n